okay this is really great for weeks now
i've been reminding you every time we
talk about fox news criticizing various
vaccine requirements at different
companies i've been reminding you fox
news
has a stricter vaccine mandate than the
one that joe biden has proposed for
companies with a hundred or more
employees as we watched tucker carlson
and laura ingram and dan bongino
criticize the requirements outlined by
joe biden
that all sorts of different companies
have adopted sports teams
airlines other organizations fox news
hosts would not mention hey our mandate
here at fox is even stricter
joe biden said get vaccinated or test
weekly fox news is doing get vaccinated
or test daily and wear a mask around
other employees if you're not vaccinated
fox news host wouldn't mention it they
would just talk about vaccine mandates
it's terrible they wouldn't mention by
the way wework it's even stricter last
week during his cnn town hall which we
covered live joe biden actually brought
this up joe biden actually said hey you
know uh
there's the cynical hypocritical
fox coverage of vaccination
they have a mandate okay so take a look
at joe biden mentioning that you know
what i find fascinating
i turn on fox to find out how popular i
am
but
how are you doing there i'm doing very
well i think i'm at three percent
favorable but
but all kidding aside one of the things
i find do you realize they mandate
vaccinations
at fox headquarters yeah
i find that mildly fascinating
mildly mildly fascinating um now that is
absolutely true
uh they mandate with the option of
testing out just like joe biden proposed
except at fox if you want to test out
you've got to test daily instead of
weekly this now
pushed fox news into needing to comment
on it they can't just pretend it's not
going on and their reaction is just to
lie and play a meaningless semantic game
that is completely bogus so take a look
at what the fox and friends crew said
the next morning about their own mandate
if you missed information he said about
fox he thought it says i think it's
funny that fox has a vaccine mandate you
have a testing option at fox so what he
said is totally inaccurate we don't have
a mandate we have a protocol right
that's a little different someone should
tell the president we don't have a
mandate here
says steve ducey we have
a protocol why
because you can test instead of getting
vaccinated but that's exactly what joe
biden proposed joe biden said vaccinate
or test weekly and fox says vaccinate or
test daily and wear a mask
and here's why
it's not a mandate but it's a protocol
is so silly just look at what the words
mean a mandate is an official order or
commission to do something well joe
biden's order is you vaccinate or test
weekly so by that definition it's a
mandate
fox news's order is vaccinator test
daily that's a mandate by this
definition it's a mandate now a protocol
is the accepted or established code of
procedure or behavior
in a group organization or situation
okay so let's look at protocol joe
biden's established code of procedure
is that you vaccinate or you test weekly
it's a protocol fox news's established
code of procedure is you vaccinate or
you test daily it's a protocol they are
both mandates of a particular protocol
this is meaningless semantic trash and i
tweeted about this over the weekend i
said
so apparently biden's required vaccine
or required weekly testing is a mandate
but fox news's required vaccine or
required daily testing
is a protocol and i received a ton of
really great responses
but one twitter user diddytrek1
lays it out the way that i did here
saying a protocol and a mandate are
synonymous
both mean something has to happen policy
is also synonymous with mandate and
protocol and that is exactly correct so
this shouldn't surprise us these are
just hypocrites these are people who
mostly want to keep their jobs even as
dan bongino
was saying
i make what dan bongino's thing with um
i think it was cumulus radio networks
although maybe he has a show on fox in a
show with a radio network it might be
cumulus he was saying listen i'm
vaccinated but i'm against any vaccine
requirements so i may quit my job here
depending on what happens
he hasn't mentioned the fact that he's
also an employee at fox which has one of
the strictest requirements now there are
some employers that have gone further
and they've said we just don't want to
deal with the testing
um or we don't want to offer a testing
option we just want everybody vaccinated
that's it and certainly that's their
prerogative and something they can
legally do
that's not actually what joe biden
proposed for companies of 100 or more
employees and what fox news has gone out
of its way to do is something that's
even stricter i have a friend who
recently started work at a um
at a west coast west coast based startup
and
during the hiring process
even right there when you apply it says
everybody on our staff has to be fully
vaccinated this allows us to do
in-person events where we can we just
test everybody on the way in and and
we've got these two layers everybody's
vaccinated and tested we can do stuff
and they they do do things just don't
apply if you're not willing if you're
not willing to be fully vaccinated by
the time you start just don't apply and
much like hey this job requires you to
work two overnights a week oh i don't
want that i'm not going to apply fine
you're being you're told up front
um that is something companies can
certainly do but that's not even what's
actually being discussed when we talk
about the joe biden requirements so it's
great that joe biden mentioning it
during the town hall thursday
pushed fox hosts to start talking about
it their reaction is so bogus their
explanation is so pathetic and and and
some man it's semantics at the end
um it shouldn't really surprise us and
we'll see my guess is that there's going
to be more commentary on this from them
the only streaming service that
specializes in documentaries is called
curiositystream they are one of our
sponsors
using the link below you can get
curiosity stream for just 15 bucks a
year which gives you access to a massive
library of the best and newest
documentaries by the world's best
documentary filmmakers i'm constantly
finding documentaries on
stream that i can't find on netflix hulu
or amazon i just finished watching a
film called
9 11 kids which is about
the kids that were in the room being
read to by former president george w
bush on 9 11
when bush learned about what happened
very interesting and well done they have
documentaries on every topic imaginable
you can watch on all of your devices if
you love documentaries like i do
curiosity stream is a must and they're
giving my audience 25 off that comes out
to just 14.99 a year you just have to go
to curiositystream.com
pacman and the link is down below